here's what would happen if you shed  your skin like a snake first you'd  notice your skin getting duller and  darker this is the pre-shedding phase  you'd start feeling tired and irritable  and you'd lose your appetite this  pre-shedding phase would take up to 14  days thankfully shedding would only last  a couple of days you would create an  opening on your forehead and peel your  old layer of skin off but you'd have to  be careful you couldn't just peel off  all your old skin at once if you shed  too quickly you could damage your new  skin so you'd remove a little every day  after a couple of days of careful  shedding you'd reach the final stage the  aftershed you'd feel like a brand new  person you'd say goodbye to  hyperpigmentation surface level scars  and any acne you had before you started  chatting and when you finish chatting  you'd have a long human-shaped shell of  yourself  so